okay but people who are joining this
livestream this is some another of a
series of meetings about a fairly
complicated topic of database
integration for from language um so
let's see where do we start here you
think from the last meeting that be sort
of halfway through okay so let's
remember what we were trying to achieve
here we're trying to get some naming and
functionality for a bunch of these
functions correct yes but that's
probably not the most important thing is
there are two one is one is the runtime
types which I think we sort of agreed
upon if you remember entity runtime
types which is I'm not sure if it's in
this notebook but this is something we
discussed before and the idea was that
as we build a query we create
generalized types which are defined by
the queries themselves rather than being
registered and have string names and so
those types have to exist on equal
footing as string types register than
the energy stores yeah yeah yeah right
okay but let's zoom out for a moment
here okay sure do we have a guide page
for this functionality yet no because a
few things have to still be figured out
for that okay let's walk through again
from the beginning let's walk through it
again okay so well first of all we're
connecting to a database here correct
yes okay and the fundamental thing we're
trying to do is to map that database
onto an entity store is that correct yes
okay so this idea that the entity store
itself has so database inspect what is
what this database inspects do it
actually connects to the database
inspects its structure and returns to us
an object which would go date SQL
database object on which is basically
their schema all right let's look at
that in put them okay so database
inspector on its own gives you this SQL
database object right yes that's correct
which can have what kind of thing so you
can make you can do it has various
properties and things like that is that
correct yes so it has the entire
information about database schema right
so for example it presumably has
information about what entities that's
really weird why is it asking that I
just did it did it crash okay so in any
case in fact I think gratefulness
because there are other input cells
there are not really nationalisation
okay in case um somewhere it must give a
list of string entity types that it
wants to introduce based on this
database schema is that correct well it
doesn't give that list directly ah
because it's you know you can you can
use certain methods to extract it right
but that's the point but then when you
say entity register here it's
registering all of those string named
entity yes right that's right which is
something that we may or may not decide
is a good idea yeah so some random
schema it's gonna spray those things
into a single namespace right yeah well
in that case it is your job to you can
even use the entry store to to to alias
those tables and Mainland differently
say you one came on kids names instead
of underscores well but how do you even
know what they are so so just given us
database so do you do you will do that
in separate set ok so tell me how given
the database object how do I find out
what the entity types that it introduces
are okay do properties of that now do
instead of properties tables so those by
default if you create an empty store
without putting anything in the first
argument or rather just putting just
passing a little bit object it's going
into those women there's a table names
those are not yeah we're mapping the
tables to the entity types that's that's
the default behavior okay so let me look
at one of those tables so for example
how do I look at the editor table from
that SQL data percent five edit or
properties okay so how do I look at how
do I get that out as the data set hmm so
far you don't okay basically basically
if you want to do it now you could do is
like you take I don't know okay but but
but I mean that seems like a desirable
thing to be able to do to get a table of
their base out of the data set yes yeah
we can I guess we can do that right and
I mean arguably okay so I'm just walking
this through from the top okay so what
we've got here at the top we have an SQL
database we are I mean I feel a bit
uneasy about putting this in to SQL
database object is the fact that in
general I scale database object
properties don't need to query the
database don't need never put a find and
then have a different way of doing it
of something another we need it's not
obvious we have we have functions to
that still did you mean by table
extracting table did you mean table data
or did you mean table date metadata no
table data I want to get that table out
as a data set okay I see I said I want
an easy way to go into the state party
yeah that I mean you need to pass DP is
the name of the object that you created
before by using dollar bet expect it's
in the shopping center and that that
that should basically work what it is
yeah
5e okay so let's walk through okay what
did that mean remove data set probably
is a problem sorry sorry remove it and
let me see this problem failure all
right okay but so let's take a look here
database so what is this return so
database table of let's say editor what
does that actually return we got a bunch
of background noise be great to actually
see one this was a wrong expression
apart from being yeah right now you
count because the Ryu's that not a
problem okay so I want it again take
this from the top so instead of out or
try editor that that should work in the
wouldn't Saddam know there is this issue
is precision which is like okay let's
let's look through this again okay so
Tony this entity store results here
which I find a little odd what is this
what is this all mean at the top here
so it's it's a list of types - metadata
about those types and this looks like a
sensible default that you can edit later
I see so there is no metadata being
provided here right this is the the
metadata is only structural that is
already the property names could be
considered metadata fair enough
so this is okay fine so and then this is
the payload here so in an entity store
normally there is no second argument
payload right it we would expect to have
the actual data in that first argument
correct actually still and I think we we
agreed that we should have second yes
yes yes we did we talked about that when
we designed right I'm just trying to
understand what the trade-off is so in
principle we could move stuff over from
the second argument to the first
argument and which wins
I mean if balls are present yeah so in
other words if I give explicit values in
the first argument does it we're not as
the second argument when I think that
for for SPL Becket's now we can't report
it yeah hold on so you can only give
metadata in the first argument when
there is a backing when when the second
argument is backed by an SQL database
exactly actually actually still I think
we I think we think that it will be more
cases consistent to have it for all the
canceling that that the actual data
lives in secular numerator as what as a
data set normally or what even just as
an association of associations
it's a back-end dependent thing I think
Tony yes can you comment on that please
about yeah I'm asking the question right
now in entity store it's possible to
have the entity property value values in
the first argument right okay so what
these guys are suggesting is
that the second argument should be able
to contain what exactly what is its
structure what is the porous structure
so the the second argument of entities
to put in principle contain any data
source then one of them is a database we
talked about the case where yes it's
directly there I understand yeah so or
the right hand side of the entity's
entry
yes that's correct okay
and that's enough is that right or does
it have to have no because the entity
store know this is like a table right
this this outer t is like a stable
correct yes that's correct I think that
when you have like data they are already
like you know structuring in a
particular way and would be great if you
can just put it in an argument instead
of you know constructing this position
with uh right but I think that the right
way to do it is not with the way you're
doing it right now I think the right way
to do it is if there is something that
comes in automatically from here that
the that this stuff instead of being
blank here has some kind of inherited or
automatic thing which means pull it in
from the second argument no but still on
the stuff and the first argument has
nothing to do with date it's all
metadata it's not look at this case it's
data look at this case in this case yes
our our proposal would be to take
basically a second argument in this case
could be Association that contains as
the keys the types then as the values
associations that each represent with
entities as the keys and properties as
notice that here there is no entities
thing is that right okay so what we're
saying is what I'm suggesting is that
what you do is in this first argument
you say entities arrow automatic
did you see what I'm saying yes but the
question is rather whether we actually
wants to support entities in the first
argument at all and if so what are the
advantages because it's convenient to
have look in small cases it's convenient
to be able to put everything in there
explicitly I think it's a fine idea
okay listen it seems like they're up
there are two different cases that are
worth supporting one is the first
argument has everything including
entities
Antoni you're with us here yes the and
the second case is that the first
argument is primarily metadata and the
main blob of data is in the second
argument right okay so now there are two
ways we could do that one is the first
argument is silent on the question of
what entities are exist and it picks
them up from the second argument and the
second approach is that it explicitly
says oh yeah for this table the entities
are automatic but I don't think that's
quite gonna work because the second
argument can refer to multiple tables
right yeah the second okay so then the
the second argument structure needs to
be something which is very much
mirroring what's in the first all yeah
you don't need the level where it says
entities I understand that I understand
which is a little confusing and well I
there is an intermediate proposal which
is that we support the the thing you
have under your mouth now as a
constructor for convenience for small
cases but then it always normalizes to
two arguments so that we don't have to
deal with kids where you instantly both
things yeah the third would not break
backward compatibility even if this
function is experimental right now so I
mean if you want to be fine Tony can you
come I get it I get it
Tony can you comment on this place
on what silicon that what we were just
discussing like using this as a click
please pay attention right using this as
a constructor in this form but having it
break the entities part removed the
entities part from the first argument
and put it in the second argument in a
different slightly different format
without the entity's level it's an
object is it a good idea I don't see a
reason by not to do it
also there is a counter argument against
entities staying in the first argument
and that is that data generically can
come from elsewhere and mixing them was
metadata they can actually create lots
of issues for people fair enough
okay look okay so provisionally we can
think about doing this and another thing
that is very easy this work right away
is that we could support a second
argument something like a file wrapper
that that points to a dot M file that
would be a very poor man version of
persisted to disk database well I agree
but I don't even know whether that's
okay but okay we're now inventing
another format here which is something
that is exactly the same as this except
it's a it's basically a collection of
associations right it's a nested
collection of associations table name
entity name property name correct yes
okay so it's very hard for me to
understand why you know I don't think it
should work that way okay I think if
we're gonna do that it should
essentially declare that that's what
it's doing by saying entities are
automatic or some such other thing in
the first argument if it's automatic
automatic so no you don't need to but
the canonical form would be to do that
so that no note so that in the future
when this thing needs
to support some kind of graph database
or some other crazy thing that we're not
oh my gosh
we just used up that syntax in argument
to have this particular structure which
I don't think is a general enough
structure if you are able to specify
like you know a back-end for each table
in the same entry store that would
remove the board was over being an
entity store in the first place because
if you are using like 10 different
databases to specify that's not what I'm
suggesting that's not what I'm
suggesting
I'm saying that syntax is suggesting
this because basically if you are able
to specify back-end for each type I'm
not suggesting that I'm suggesting that
either it says automatic in which case
it comes from the second argument or it
can be given explicitly in which case
it's right there okay I don't think it's
a good idea because I think one wants a
case where some of these things might be
tiny little tables that are explicitly
given here and other ones might be big
things which are in the second argument
it's not a good idea because you can't
normalize it what are you going to
normalize it to because if you've got
this thing you can't wait wait wait wait
you can't combine the normalization of
this little you know table with this big
SQL database but you can't you can't do
that anyway present we cannot hopefully
we will be able to you if you have
multiple pi can't you just write this is
what the entity stories I understand I
understand listen we don't need to solve
this problem let's move on okay another
thing that I want to record here is that
the second argument doesn't need to be
an
that list of associations especially for
graph like the diet could be an
adjacency list okay what's going to
declare what it is
Carlo that's the point I keep on making
a c1 if I may make a comment on this
then I think given that the data sources
will be diverse and different the right
thing to do would be to define an
interface they satisfy rather than they
declare their structure in declarative
way possibly yes which means that
they've got to be wrapped somehow which
means that you can't take this naked
thing and put it in the second argument
so we can take that off the table for
now yes exactly
okay so in terms of a file backed thing
which I think would be nice what an
earth would that file look like I mean
back in the day we were intending the
data set have a file backed possibility
and right now we're not allowing you
know a single table in this database
could back a data set right am I making
sense yes of course with some
limitations that is correct
but but it could absolutely back a data
set and I think we should support that
yes but that's I think a separate
discussion no no I understand but I want
to understand what the what the strategy
for doing that is that is what it would
roughly look like I mean the original
plan was the data set could be backed by
a file and it was automatically and I
believe we made a lot of progress on
that does anybody know yeah well it was
my project meaning I think right yes
that's right about streaming well I
don't know what I'm talking about
streaming I'm talking about being able
to have a file here is a dot CSV file
and have that be something that
automatically be used
yeah so that's someone separate but yeah
we've had a plan for that okay so let's
just talk about that for a second okay
okay so where the thing would be left on
disk and would you know coming to memory
as needed so what was the thing that you
what you ended up building was something
where it has already been pre-prepared
as a dot M X Files yes
right so okay so you have first step is
to convert the CSV file into an MX file
right it was not just one index file it
was generically whatever I don't care
it's some some place some local object
right so what you're saying is there is
some function that converts the CSV file
into a local object anoraks dataset can
then refer to the local object
correct correct okay so what what and
the concept there so what would happen
to that
well that project was almost completed
but there were a few technical problems
that I still had to resolve and the
biggest the biggest problem was that we
can't possibly hope to support the
entire richness of data set by using
that framework because it was not only
filed back per se but it was a shot of
course so we should separate two notions
here Steven one notion is supporting by
different objects like for example
single file which is sort of one thing
so like generalized data set to support
like multiple being backed by multiple
things and the other thing is to support
lazy out of core operations yeah so lazy
is a different that's you I mean yes
okay because you've got a whole big
theory of laziness for the whole
database system right so as we think you
know data set is not a lazy you know
it's a thing which does its operations
immediately it doesn't have to because
all this query language is not actually
eager necessarily eager and in fact what
I developed was streaming was an
illustration that you don't have to be
younger but the bottom line is we could
have something where you take a CSV file
you have
operation that converts it into your
format right yes yes or we could take if
I'm not mistaken but maybe it's
pointless a database table and convert
it to your format it's not pointless and
that hope does at some point where we'll
connect this thing two things together
but it's not pointless why are you.why
Koosh why shouldn't you just use that
stuff in the database why why should
they not use which stuff in the database
the data that you're describing here in
the database rather than in why why
would we convert the database data to my
format yes because database data is
sometimes huge and may not fit in memory
but we don't but none of this stuff is
making a better memory I mean the great
base query system is specifically making
the queries happen on the database
server not in memory right but you need
to extract them for the user and bring
them to to or from language to
Mathematica
well certain circumstances but well okay
okay
okay so hold on so I'm trying to
understand how this relates because
clearly one thing we absolutely need to
be able to do it's a very minimal thing
much less fancy than a lot of what we're
trying to do here is you've got data
it's in a database I want to do data set
operations on it
so this one is comparatively easier
still on because we've developed the
entire layer that to which database rank
where language can be compiled provided
that you only deal with rectangular data
sets okay wait a second wait a second
wait a second if the data set is coming
from an external SQL database then by
definition it's rectangular correct okay
so the case that we're talking about is
data set of an SQL database object or
some such other thing specifically that
a specific table in that be able to
reference in this way right so let me
refresh your memory on that a little bit
about the yeren that half ago I was
giving a demo where I was showing that
you can compile data set query language
with
a few extensions to basically warakorn
databases and so now we have the
infrastructure that will make it
possible to compile the core language to
our internal layer so that's that's very
very possible okay okay so again at that
point you made a point that we want to
support entities as our final front ends
so to speak first and that's what we've
been doing okay Ron yeah but we made an
infrastructure that would allow data set
to be supported too so just so I
understand I mean in the hold on so a
data set
a typical random data set doesn't
necessarily have rows that are labeled
by entities you know a typical random
data set could just be you know for
example something like this I mean I
could just say data set of you know
random integer you know 10 you know
something like this right now
actually let me let me just do the
single table version of that the 2d
table version of that okay so is there a
sense in which that can be meaningfully
represented as a database probably not
because you need names for the table for
the columns
okay so so in other words in the SQL
world there is no meaningful way in
which one can have an unnamed column set
up there is one but it does it's not
supported in all backends there are data
types called arrays where you can just
have an array which can be
multi-dimensional okay okay I'm sorry I
mean you need a name for the whole array
no no no I understand that I understand
that but but so an individual table so
the point is that you're saying they
have to be entities those entities will
normally be local entities of a base
they will not be global entities no into
our system is that right Tony and others
Tony it sounds right to have some kind
of non registered entities in which you
can work but this is the whole idea of
having an entity store which the point
the throne entities yes and working it
visit without registering it
okay okay fine so these will be fairly
the things you get from databases will
be fairly special datasets
yes abstract the data set but it will be
a fairly special data set yes as opposed
to the things that and again we need to
understand this roadmap I mean the basic
roadmap would be that the things that
will be being picked up into your
streaming format Leonard will be things
that are basically coming from external
files people well what's the what's the
what's beyond that example there can be
all kind of files that allows streaming
import not necessarily see speed no no I
understand that but I'm saying I'm
saying the the source would be it could
be an HTM file it could be you know a
bunch of other file formats yes
but fundamentally it yeah and it can
also be a database well I don't
understand that I mean I mean slice it
you can you can filter again and see you
just need to support basically order
especially like for the formatting when
you when you click a column if we are
acquiring with ten columns we kind of
could run the query only with that
column that you clicked and and when you
scroll when you go to the next page that
is just an offset so when you have a
query and you just need to do something
like that based off query and that will
basically two things only in the front
end or when you start mapping stuff yes
so so maybe maybe what me what me
explain the distinction the distinction
is this you can create like page table
object that essentially will always call
a database for the next page
alternatively you can upload the entire
data set into the streaming format and
then all the other operations you
perform on it which support are
supported by streaming object will be
supported from within the module from
kernel right and I think that would be
nice because basically it's sometimes
happen that you have done a query and
the word is small enough now to continue
in memory
and so like money for 100 elements and
then use the opposite to continue melody
in the opposite situation it's like yes
so there is also a middle ground where
the latest it is too big to fit in
memory it's not too big to fit on this
girl and you want to perform operation
to cut me run under their campaigns but
cannot be run without ranking then you
just do a query that is smaller or you
think it's lies I mean yes the point is
that that at any stage in this process
once you've got a result from a database
query you can basically wrap it in data
set and you will have something which
will automatically figure out does it
move the whole thing into memory doesn't
scream the thing etc because then you
don't need to write okay so let's
continue here okay so I think I get this
so I'm sorry
we tracked with respect to the no we're
not we're not we're really working up to
the main theme where we're trying to
make sure we have a good foundation here
right so maybe what do you want them to
maybe make some sections or would you
just remember because I mean one of the
problems is that in all these meetings
apparently we don't have any notes which
is really kind of an upsetting yeah I
mean is Dominic you making notes from
this I am making notes understand I've
got some older meetings archive it as
well because I think we at least need to
structure our you know discussion so
that something is left and we remember
that we were discussing oh you want me
to basically make the notes from this so
then
okay so let's let's look at this in them
so first issue is we're saying so I
don't know whether why is it cool
database inspect why is that not just
database connect because it does
different things than just connecting
you know it more or it doesn't only
connect to return the schema if you want
just one okay okay so database Connect
returns does it return a database object
as well and as killed everybody we are
managing the connection internally we we
have this function if we want to expose
it but basically the way it works is
that we are over in the connection at
the very last moment so by default I
think you don't need to connect by end
you just run a query and with a kind of
a winning connection if there is no one
then there is a system to query the
connection that are dominant and you
enclose them that's that's that's
probably important I think disconnect is
part important then connect that we have
we we have the system in place so we
have a database connection object that
contains database information and you
can actually different from an SQL
database object right yes
just just do database connection I think
of the percent five I guess so database
connection right okay so this is the
object that is inside SQL database
object and you can see what's inside
with the input form it's really
straightforward but yeah or you can do
that it's basically two keys back and in
this case SQLite but otherwise it's
back-end like my sequel and then lost
password domain and this kind of stuff
and yeah this is where the connection is
a sub part of the SQL database object is
that correct
it doesn't have to be it can be also
used
I mean especially in this case since the
bidam is actually a fire when you look
at this they okay okay okay okay that's
in general the idea that we were adding
was this basically each time you have a
function that can that can do basic
enumeration on the database like
database query or inspect or something
you can pass the schema schema can
contain the connection but you can also
have passed to the other function to the
outside function connection goes through
and you pass another connection that
that takes the priority and so a with
the same schema right right okay right
you can have a master slave
configuration or you can create a master
slave configuration like that you okay I
think there are too many functions here
I don't understand okay so and why this
is called SQL database object and this
is simply called database connection I
have no idea that's because stealing
because database connection is supposed
to be on internal object we right now
they only expose and SQL database object
is supposed to be something that we are
going to document base connection can be
used in spite of stuff so which is why
okay so this is a general connector yes
SQL database object has a lot of
machinery like tables etc that don't
exist
this is why we're trying to
differentiate that with the SQL predicts
okay also as far as I know like if you
have an RDF had point you can just say
tell me what the shape of the data is
there's no equivalent reading of
database inspection for RDF is that
correct Tony yes in some sense instead
of asking for schema which is a
different operation you would just write
some queries check what other properties
and so on
okay and some are given and points have
also apologies that you can query yes
it's kind of wrong that I'm writing
these notes I mean it's kind of like why
are we working any other notes then well
but in the way you are driving the
discussion define okay so we can take
can take database query and turn it into
a data set
right now the other thing is
out of core operations we talked about
and they're what we talked about is
convert from an external file
eg CSV hdf etc to a streaming blob what
did you call those well the last thing
was streaming data set but ok so fine so
it's streaming blob which can then be
accessed by through data set by queries
right yes except yeah that's correct
okay right if you've got just there but
I'm not going to discuss ok fine fine
fine fine ok so then a streaming blob as
we're calling it for right now
might also be produced from a database
query correct and even then it can be
produced in two distinct ways okay we
don't need to know about that right now
yes yes okay all right so entities store
design okay what we discussed is should
the payload should the value payload
always go in the second argument and our
opinion meaning database group is yes
right well I think the my argument would
be we should allow it in either argument
in the first Arg
we should have eg you know entities goes
to automatic
optionally to indicate that it's in the
second argue that it can be found in the
second dog or that can be omitted I
think we might want later to have a
separate dedicated discussion on this
okay well I think we should implement it
as like this and we'll go from there
okay so let's keep going okay so the
next issue is that you really want to
talk about
what is all this stuff runtime okay so
basic types yes this I think this is
about Iran time types and the related
notion of all these operations below and
it is selected
yeah right okay so these are things
let's see
[Music]
you
so they want me to remind you in like a
few general words what was this about
what do you remember I more or less
remember but I want to know what the
overall roadmap of what we're trying to
do is so we had talked before about some
of these horrendous things like entity
join it cross and so on right yes but
from our current viewpoint of this
meeting I think these are more like
specific details okay so the generic
thing that we were discussing was that
in the energy store in an entity
framework originally only string entity
types who were allowed in things like
you know entity property for example
[Music]
okay
and then what we realized is that these
new extensions these new query
primitives such as entities select or
any sort by etcetera they introduced new
types which are defined by the query
itself not by a string or anything like
that okay so this is so did you review
this with Toni separately
Toni wasn't in the last meeting which
was kind of a goof I think there is
still a couple of things where Tony is
not 100% on the same table itself and
maybe should speak about Abel page
whatever you've been doing database is
too long go ahead um okay but let's
let's review then what you had said
it's an example of a composite Lee named
construct here oh but the oh you mean
you mean a runtime type or there are two
separate issues the one you're looking
at is a kind of runtime type is that
what you mean because there was a time
and okay naming of generated entity
types is what you're saying yes and so
there our argument was that you you have
to simply use the query like in earth
query itself that defines for you the
time you know this runtime time as a
representation of that and so in
particular in the first argument of
entity property you should allow such
things
okay so let's remember what entity does
right now so if I say entity and you
keep on telling me it's really entity
class but I'm you know so if I do
something like this
okay
okay I get that rather useless thing out
and I have to do entity list if I've
actually want to resolve where do I want
to do entity value you didn't never want
to do anything that you actually what do
you care about you care about the names
and the populations so you enter the
value of that I don't agree with you
I don't agree I'm sorry I think that's a
fake you know that's the truth like we
were talking about it last time if you
do
Anton lists and then you do any value as
a separate operation then I mean
countries don't change that open but the
data might have changed whatever the
okay so are you saying if I say that of
name oh it does work okay so if I say
that of name population
okay so this is Tony ISM and it's
working fine
yeah it's I think that Tony is also
coming around to liking doing things in
120 value well yet it's always been the
preferred way because why first resolve
a potentially large class two entities
and then send the entities back to the
server to retrieve the data new Oh fair
enough
the we tell uses this undocumented we
are trying to document preferred way
okay all right okay but let's go back
now to the case of the database case
right yeah
and that actually is not just database
case because these are new these new
primitives query parameters are going to
be universally supported by the entity
framework okay well fine so let's give
an example and give an example of where
this okay give an example of the analog
of this in a more sophisticated case if
you use something like inside entity
class if you use something like well
actually entities to act of and it
across country and please select the
country country okay and then the second
argument of energy to act is going to be
any function well what happened to the
entity class here what am I saying here
I think you should say comma all
groaning yes and what should I do that
and here is that correct to me yes okay
fine go ahead
and then you write any function and then
Open bracket variable no another string
likes a country lower case variable
comma and then country Open bracket
string population for example small or
larger than some number okay and so now
I run that and it doesn't run because
this is an earth query and to run it you
need to wrap entity value around it and
request certain property
what is the C requested expected because
currently you can't compare units with
few numbers you're going to fix that
right there is a bug report but not all
people agree because what can happen is
if you say one person equals one and one
equals one Apple then you say personally
kappa because equal is transitive
so people are hesitant to make this
change well so we need some way to deal
with this so we'll need a separate
discussion is unbelievably slow it might
not yet support a quantity inside entity
function but this is like maybe we could
take some you can try something that so
the thing I did before with the take
largest how would we do that there will
be two operations to that you need to
first take like sort and he's sorted by
and then after that name right because
we should be able to do a take largest
directly I mean without having to have
some weird function called entity take
largest yes but the thing is that and
take largest from the point of view of
tables or like sets like you know it's
not it's not a primitive operation it's
a composite operation understand but
that's not for us it's not ok so what
this is saying
so here what are we doing here we would
say entity class
and then we would give a pure function
greater than
and now we say 10 to the 8 people is
that correct yes that was our formal way
of doing it
yes that's correct okay but the reason I
gave the example with entity select is
that even though I don't like by the way
I don't like how do we get out entities
here I mean I guess we say entity list
but that's a very you know I don't like
getting just these names out anyway
entity but on the other hand in terms of
practical work that people do they are
more often interested in specific
properties than just a list of entities
some things okay right okay fine but but
so what we've got here is a this is the
alternative way using entities select is
on the entity class is the alternative
way of use it of dealing with this
shorthand notation where this is
effectively an implicit entity select
yes except it has the additional
property that we can say take largest
whatever which we are not supporting
here for some reason because what this
really is is you know some kind of
entity function type I don't know what
how to think about this right this is
something you're correct that's right
but it's so this is a different
construct than you have right now entity
celesia so in the entity class the issue
is that the right hand side in general
are predicates but there are some
exceptions that are not predicates like
take largest or
nearest to and they are handled
specially because they are not predicate
but so how would those be handled in the
full form these things here like greater
than the rule syntax will be converted
to entity select okay fine but I'm
asking about things like you know
nearest to or take Lord or take largest
okay so here are the strategy I think is
the following you reconstruct I
represent that by two operations like
candy sort boy and entity something like
entity take of given number and then
I'll have optimizations that will take
into account that
for example you don't have to sort the
entire thing to just extract a few okay
but but we have a nice syntax here with
Anthony class and it would be nice if
there was a full version of that syntax
that supported the same kinds of things
rather than if you're not using that
syntax you have to go in this multi-step
thing but the problem statement is that
the new syntax that is based on this new
operations like and it is selects or by
it's either is strictly more powerful in
general so I'm saying that it should
degenerate there should be a path where
it degenerates to this that doesn't
require multi-step it's probably an
additional operation in the entity
select world yeah I guess we could
introduce an additional operations such
as entity greater than misery no no no
no I I don't think you need that I don't
think you need that you need some kind
of general you know entity I don't know
I'm making this up okay entity apply to
an entity class of something like take
largest blah blah blah that's the wrong
way to do it it will be
but this is more or less what are we or
what I also suggest because the entity
apply is effectively just saying that
you are building up a query right I
understand that but I'm talking about
what the user thinks right the user
thinks this is as if I'm applying this
operation to this class see what I'm
saying yes except except if we have like
I mean if you apply something to it
class as a whole it would make sense to
apply it externally to a class rather
than having it as a second argument I
think well okay no look look look look
look look
the issue is okay the issue is this if
you have an entity class right so let's
say I have an entity class I don't even
know how we refer to all countries okay
so it's a entity class country all that
I guess is our way of referring to all
countries okay now I could do I could
say take
you
let's see
what I've got is a property
so what I'm saying is
take largest buy this is the curried
form
oh boy that's something kind of
complicated but but you get what I'm
saying that we want something which is
the full version of this
kind of syntax right that doesn't
involve multiple steps let's come back
to that it's like how would you even
like there's no way you can do that
could directly with sweat right so no I
don't think you can do it directly with
select so you need a different function
to do this I mean and there's like a
very simple example that's ready beyond
what does having a list of rules can do
which is like if you have an or just
position oh right I understand that's
why I'm asking for a function that does
this in a full of form so that you can
actually manipulate the pieces all right
now what is the operation so for the
general I think there's mistake in
reasoning in that you're thinking that
you can say just apply a bunch of take
largest select and so on but the thing
is that we have like 5,000 functions and
moves for 10 there no more
so what's the point well we've already
got that issue with entity class right
there are only certain predicates that
will work here yeah and that's that's
why I think it's better to have like
these okay I don't think so I think we
want to function along that we can loop
back to this but we're going to want a
function can we can we put this on the
list and not forget it
we'll need a function that does the
equivalent of entity class
blah blah blah blah blah blah arrow blah
blah blah okay
let's come back to that bone
do is go on here yeah III did the main
question that I want to discuss with
Tony is do we want single entities of
this rant on tides and if so what is
their first argument yes and wait what
we already suggested and actually still
when we already went was that with you
on that was that the first argument in
that case should be the entire in earth
query that represents this front intact
okay but but I just want to see an
explicit example here do we have that
please yeah but we kind of started it
with you just a few minutes ago was that
entity select examples of that okay so
let me see an example so this is this an
example so no go you have to look at the
entity what entities returns so for
example aunt if you scroll down into
your goodies back in the examples with
entity annotate and three cross don't
really change much but if you can't
really by there is an example I'm not
understanding this so let's take a look
at this one here so this here is a some
class of some entity class right and if
I wanted to I could say entity list of
that what the heck yeah what the heck is
that the heck is that because we had
that bog that's made it into the build
okay so what would this so normally what
this would do is produce something which
are yellow boxes like this is that
correct yes the question is what is the
input form of those yellow boxes okay
and what is the output form also
so those yellow boxes if the thing has a
name if the entity has a name that right
Oh what are those numbers there well
that's the primary key of the database
table so that's the canonical name of
the entity
okay economically so right now this is
represented as that that's the raw table
content in the yeah we already know so
the thing is that you if you in the
Anton story you can set a label property
that can use a string join up first
thing last name um whatever it is but
that's the thing that appears in the
yellow box the label is what appears in
the yellow box yeah in this case nobody
said the label so weird I understand so
you're using the primary key and that's
all good now the question is what
happens if the thing that you are
looking at where you need to where you
do entity list isn't something that is
coming directly from a database table
with primary keys and so on right not
only that's doing when it comes directly
from a query that involves erase or
several transformations I understand of
what is this dude did you want to share
the screen and just show me what this
does right now it's not very interesting
no one does it do ya what does it do it
would be basically entity of that whole
antes like type of blah blah blah comma
tell me what so you have that example in
your notebook on the left if you go and
this entity group by aggregate by here
you see that's the example entity list
here yeah and you see it returns a list
of energies and each entity contains a
large expression as a first argument
okay okay I get it okay so let's look at
what that is so that is in the first
argument it is the unn resolved I mean
normally is because wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait normally there will be
two things here there will be the entity
type and the specific name of the entity
right exactly so what is this so this is
the name of the entity but this is
something that we wanted to discuss with
you as a next stop
no no no we resolve that but what is
that what's that supposed to be so if
there is if it's a basic table and it
has only one primary key it's gonna be
just that otherwise its entity least and
perhaps an association that goes
property goes to value
well what wait a second wait a second
what are you saying so this thing okay
you have got
you are basically making a synthesized
entity store write an on-the-fly
synthesized entity store did it die by
what saying no no it's no think of it
this way okay no no just a second okay
imagine you take an entity store Tony
are you with us yes okay imagine you
take an entity store and you make a
transformation to the entity store right
now the only thing we can do at runtime
CC let's say for example we wanted to
create a new virtual property in an
entity store
to be attached to some type Stern okay
that's fine dandy that's lovely
terrific okay let's say it combines two
types in the entity store
okay let's say it's the I don't know
some something that
I could join for example yes okay and we
are essentially synthesizing something
which is like a runtime created piece of
the entity store yes yes but our claim
is that it's again a new type rather
than a new entity store I'm asking you
independent of databases and dependent
external disk for a in-memory entity
store is there not a way to create
effectively a synthesized type
synthesized extra pieces of the data
entity store yeah but that's exactly the
point that we have to support it well I
understand that I understand but I'm
asking the question independent of all
of these operations like entity
aggregate by and so on which are lazy
operations I'm asking in I'm asking Tony
in the case of the entity store what are
what is something which you can do sort
of immediately in memory how does that
work
so question maybe not but first of all I
think that entity store is a container
that happens to contain one or more
types and then you can work on each of
these types independently and there's
nothing more you can do okay but let's
say we synthesize a property in the
sense of adding a computed property to a
type
that's correct yeah so so this is an
operation abstractly defined it has
nothing to do with entity store
I think the entity stores just a
container for types okay but let's
imagine that you had pre computed a
commune oh you you because what's
happening here is that you're
effectively yes you can synthesize new
entity types but you can also synthesize
new entity properties right you can
create an entity property here a virtual
entity property yes but because that
property is going to be belonging to
some type you effectively are
synthesizing a new type okay I don't
care I don't care the point is in the
entity store world right you're
similarly you could imagine taking an
entity store and for that entity store
synthesizing a new property for all
entities of a given type
yes yes and our claim is that by doing
this you are defining new type whatever
you can say that if you want to but
either way no but some either way that
that's that's database thinking I don't
think particularly it is because it's
you have to define a new table and
database world it's more than a database
thinking Steven because we have a notion
of entity type in the entity story do
remember we went through this we had the
hierarchy you actually suggested that
that you have a hierarchy which starts
with an ad store then goes to type then
goes to you know I I know that I know
that I know that I'm asking you but in
the case where you are referring to so
in some cases okay some properties just
have explicit names because they had to
be named because they were set up that
way in when the entity store is set up
okay but imagine that you have a
property that is synthesized it's the
square of some other property let's say
okay yeah it doesn't have a name all you
know about it is it's the square of the
radius or some it can't not have okay so
walk me through that because that's what
you're talking about here is things that
haven't been given names that are only
defined by their operation that produces
them can so the way we do that is if you
enter the value at that yeah the value
of title string comma int function
X comma X PRIZE or the square bracket
prices three times - yeah apart from
that
that doesn't work so that's the
temporary property death it's not being
even ice what you're saying okay so
that's an example so entity function
okay so so in other words the conclusion
here is entity function lets you create
a quotes virtual property yeah just like
pure functions let you do that for in
normal case for you know good point and
if you want to mean that use it later
that's what we should be calling to the
extent that was and see annotate in the
version before okay so lets you create
virtual properties you know but what can
we call it analogous to analogous to
function okay so now you're saying
entity extend
let's one name those virtual properties
is that correct and not only that but it
then attaches that named property to
certain type okay so fine so that's
exactly what I was talking about here so
so walk me through Tony there's an
entity functional entity function work
on a on a built-in type yes the idea is
to have all of these entity functions be
supported by all backends okay so fine
so let's say that I say
[Music]
entity value of country
,
say population x times
[Music]
uh times 100
actually let me let me do something
different here let me let me do
something more interesting okay let me
say X of GDP slash population right you
can try it it might even work I love
your confidence it's not optimized
because it's still prototyped okay but
that's that's okay fine but that's super
interesting then to understand that okay
so that's the way that you create a
virtual property so to speak
right mm-hmm and that's basically for at
least for us that's a shorthand of being
it's valuable it's to a smaller version
of this let's say um entity class what
can I do
let's say something like countries in
South America countries in in North
America that should be very easy right
you
how come there's so many countries in
North America
Caribbean okay who knows who cares but
that's magnificent
that's great I love it
okay so we're I too want to say entity
extend here yeah you would do something
like I guess that in the branch you have
it still called entity on the trait but
so you do want to value of entity well
you know what just do entity its I don't
think there's an entity value there I
think it's an entity extend which
returns what does it return it doesn't
return also if you want it to work it's
conventional to eat there no I
understand but I want to write it out
correctly and then I'll copy it down to
little bit well of that class of
countries yeah okay
oh but that's not an entity class right
what's right entity no but if that was
the list of entities just right there
but it shares the same I mean you just
extend the whole okay then what will it
set what would I say comma and then GDP
PP whatever you want to call it okay
okay and then I wrote that entity
function okay and then what is this
going to return and nothing and then you
have to atone even what like you have to
apply that works like an entity class
so most called entity entity annotate
annotate yeah okay now you wanna after
that open quote after that you wanna do
some values
[Music]
my gosh
call asaurus
[Music]
okay I understand okay so then this
entity extend
if that's really the right name
I'm wondering whether it should be more
like entity extension by the way I
didn't want to do that for all of these
entities selection entity etc Terra
Terra yes but still and there are some
arguments against this naming and one of
them is that all these operations are
sort of lazy and in a sense more like
curried form and so it's in select also
has a curried form and is lazy in that
sense it's closer to that business the
current form is it not the current form
doesn't look very curried to me
well it's curved in the sense that you
have to I mean that thing you just did
that with the sum is not courage in that
sense it's good I mean the antis is
select is not walk me through the
entities select here the entities
this doesn't look at all curried to me
no then then if you want something out
you have to say you know give me the
title yeah but what's the non curried
form of entities select is there should
be one I mean because I don't think you
can have it
listen if there is no non curried for
each guy and also entity glass right and
so on because the entity course if you
got it with sub value you get out of
property and so on semantically when I
mean what I'm saying it's the class is a
noun
entities select is a verb you are right
you're right but what I I mean what I
don't like about Phi I think that in
general you're right in principle about
having nouns the thing is that trying to
go out with those nouns led to very
weird things okay so that's like worry
now not join across okay we're going to
figure that out
it makes the see also in with the rest
of language much easier now C and D
select is like select no it's not like
select it's like selection because
unless we can give it a non curried form
unless we can give it something where
you know for example and I'm not
suggesting this particularly a three
argument form in which it doesn't
immediately a value
in other words if we can argue if we can
document something where there is an
immediate form where it's not purely
curried then I would go for that
otherwise I think we have to name them
with nouns Oh what do you think we might
need a separate design meeting for they
I mean that would make sense I think
it's kind of a separate topic which has
lots of arguments you know sorry say
that again what I'm saying that this
topic of naming I think it would deserve
but I strongly think okay so let me make
a note here you know should it be entity
select or enter this selection
so if entities select it will need a non
curried form okay but the thing that you
wanted to raise here is the entity type
specification and we're running out of
time here but I now understand after a
lot of flapping around here I now
understand this notion of a virtual of a
pop-up property but basically so what
you are describing is how do we make a
pop-up tight yes okay and the way is to
simply take in North query and declare
that that is a pop-up type okay so this
you
okay so right so fine so you're saying a
query I don't see any problem with that
I mean that we've been through that
already and you agreed so I think we are
more like kind of repeating and
finalizing that but but now in that case
that is the pop up type okay so let's
take this as an example right so that's
an example of something with a pop up
type however when you have a pop up type
like that there is a question of what
you name the individual entities within
the pop up type is that correct yes and
that's a kind of a lost or separate
question or which we also discuss two
issues with this one is what is the
yellow box form of the pop up type
that's one question and the other is
what's the naming of the individual
entity in the pop up type
right does it turn what is the print
form and what is the entity name right
so normally what we would do in one of
these things is we would say well in the
output we don't say the type name
normally right so in an input if we say
UK for example we'll see the type name
there as country right yeah so in in
this case you know if we were to see a
type name it would be some kind of
computed type name but the more
interesting question is what is the
entity name
yeah and that's also the one that we
discussed at length in the breeze
meetings for what would you be conclude
I think we concluded that the form is
this that is represented here that you
have a no but that's not it that's not
at the print form all the prints form
yeah what is the print form it means for
the name yeah and what is this this this
is some weird thing in a special context
so that's not really a real thing except
that this entity IDE is going to either
make it to a non special context or
replaced by some other identifier okay
so this is the thing where we were
considering mapping this into the
external identifier business yes yes yep
okay so that
external identifiers I see so we were
considering just entity ID of that thing
or entity identifier of that thing is
that correction yes as okay so then fine
I mean what's wrong with that
so then then it could be either some
kind of weird key thing inside the
database or something you know or
something different but then there's the
question of what is the print form of
this I think we either need to be able
to label that in the entity store or we
need to basically give some heuristic
for deciding what it is given you know
given them the data that's here yeah YUM
I think the easiest way is to all the
user to instruct how this should be no I
agree what once if you're labeling it
but I think we've gotta have a heuristic
if the user didn't say anything yeah
yeah sure sure okay
listen we ran out of time yeah go ahead
we can of worms but if we ran out of
time it's not you well okay you can say
it but then we're not going to do it
let's meet it okay so a question is so
there are some cases were changing the
runtime type clearly effects that
whatever the primary keys are and so on
so it's obvious that the runtime type
has changed but if you take something
and you resort it then one could argue
that you don't need that that the type
hasn't changed but I think it should
because those things can be deeply
nested and if you decide not to change
it for the trivial cases then you know
it's a mistake I think that's enough
as a shinai mean if you choose to make
that optimization well-known but the
fact is who cares well the time then the
question becomes like our if you do
entity class of country g8 the entities
that come out are of type country or a
type of type entity class country g8
i'll say ii know but that's not correct
it's not correct they resolve down they
evaluate down to the base entity type
they can't always do that okay like you
know sometimes a you know an expression
with you know nested square roots can
evaluate down to the number three and
sometimes it cannot yeah once these are
ones you have like five nested levels of
this stuff then i mean you have you can
peel some of the outer ones but not all
of them right so it's it's a question of
is there a canonical form are there
functions for getting canonical forms is
there an equivalent tester all the usual
stuff we ran out of time let's continue
this preferably you know by the
beginning of next week so we haven't
lost context here one problem was next
week steven is that we all are going to
the conference on Tuesday we're doing so
you guys figure out what you want to do
okay but next time can we make sure we
have a proper agenda and can we make
sure that we've actually cleaned what we
had here and maybe tried to start
generating guide pages and things yeah
and I think there's even if I may make a
suggestion I would start next time with
clearly stating which things we firmly
agree on which are kind of sealed and
what we were trying to do this time I
think we've gotten a long way with that
yes the next things we have to do here I
think we need to look at these
operations I think we're actually in
pretty good shape here we just need to
make you know see the stuff actually be
implemented as we've specified
you know I really think we're in quite
good shape yeah okay but you know things
like this entity aggregate and so on an
entity join across there's going to be
some you know we need to work through
those a bit okay all right okay thank
you all thank you to people on the
livestream who've been remarkably silent
this is probably a head spinning topic
um but to be continued
talk to you later